wow i look older
you noticed i'm aging
it's not itching at all
three
two
well i i first have to say steve what an
absolute pleasure to meet you
you're one of those journalists i think
every journalist looks up to is inspired
by your storytelling
it's magnificent and i know viewers love
that well thank you wow
i was going to stay no matter what you
said well yeah i've gotta butter you up
first no i'm kidding um
you know talking about storytelling and
that's that's so important and it's so
critical especially when you have these
incredible shows that you were able to
take part of
for you
what is it that makes a good story how
is it what is it that makes it the one
that's interesting because we do get a
lot of suggestions we go through a lot
of ideas we generally try to pick
something that when all is said and done
and the story's over that people will
feel something and ideally
we want people to feel overwhelming joy
because you know news in general doesn't
do a great job with joy we can do fear
pretty well and anger but joy can be
elusive sometimes but i think it's
really important and i think it's more
reflective of the real america than a
lot of what comes at the beginning of
the news guest so i just think it's
really important to have it in there and
if people end the newscast and our
stories always come at the end you know
feeling optimistic
have their faith in humanity restored
then it's a good day
this franchise has been around for a
long time
does it make it easier now to weed
through some of these stories i assume
they're falling in your lap and you
don't have to go out and solicit for
them at this point
no they're not falling at our lap
media's so fractured now you know
there's so many people watching this and
that and so we don't know we don't get a
lot of people sending us ideas
but that's okay we'll we'll go out and
find them and and my producer scours the
local newspapers and goes to the
internet and tries to find just the
right thing to end the week so that that
is how it works it's still old-fashioned
journalism yes yeah it's not people
sending us ideas generally no that's
very interesting i would have thought
that that would have been so much easier
when charles corral did this job you
know 50 years ago when he started people
would send in things to cbs because it
was just cbs nbc and abc and everybody
watched charles kuralt and he would have
a folder if he's going to poughkeepsie
he would have like a folder of 100 story
ideas he could do in poughkeepsie it's
not that way anymore it's a little we
have to sort of work a little harder to
find our ideas
speaking of working a little bit harder
during the pandemic we all worked a lot
harder things changed so much for us for
you as you storytell around america but
you're not meeting these folks face to
face and you're doing it virtually what
was that like how did that change your
perspective it was really hard you know
i do on the road and all of a sudden i'm
in my house you know it's not the nature
of the segment we did the best we could
over zoom i incorporated my children
and did some things with them because
i'm stuck at home and they're in my
office hounding me anyway might as well
put them on tv so we did some of that
but i'm glad that it's over because
something's lost when you can't go out
and actually meet people face to face
and we're going places that cbs news
doesn't get to as often as sometimes
it's the back roads it's the smaller
towns and i think it's important to get
out there and represent those folks too
it is important to to represent all of
america
and you mention your children
they have certainly become part of your
storytelling so are we paying them yet
how's that going to work do they want to
be journalists good question are we
paying them no we're not but they do ask
sometimes
that started because you get stuck at
home and
schools around the country have you know
had been using our stories to teach
character education we we knew this so
that when the pandemic happened and kids
were stuck at home we started something
we called kindness 101
where we took stories and we sort of
framed them and used them to teach
lessons on on empathy or gratitude or
honesty integrity and
and it was pretty successful but we
found that it was meant for kids but it
was mostly adults who were watching this
thing so now cbs is putting that on the
broadcast on cbs morning so my kids are
now on broadcast television and i know
that they're going to be asking for an
increase in allowance because of it
you're anticipating it yes
i love that and i love that you're able
to showcase a little bit of your family
that becomes real you know the reality
of what it's like to work at home for so
many people who were stuck yeah it was
really because they would come in and
they're they want to tell me everything
and you know
you don't have to work from home very
often but for those who do they know
it's very hard because you know you
don't get more than like a few minutes
at a time before somebody's asking you
for something or and i feel so guilty
that can you come outside and play with
us i i feel like i have to say yes every
time
and do you i do
and you're a good dad yeah i guess so so
does that come first dad and then
journalist yeah i try i try to do it
that way but it you know it can be
stressful
i think every parent can probably
understand that
what is it that you think your stories
do for people the ones who are at home
who are watching
what do those stories give to them
what i'm trying to do through my work is
is remind people of what america is
really all about
and it's about people helping each other
people getting along whether they're
democrat or republican when you come
face to face with somebody you don't
care what their politics are you don't
care what their skin color is
people
like each other and i think we need to
be reminded of that and people are good
people are good
you know there are certain exceptions of
course but by and large people are good
and i just want to remind people of that
you know week in and week out
is that your goal for each story
it is it is to to reaffirm again restore
faith in humanity
and and present a true picture it's not
like i'm presenting just a
rosy image of america i feel like i'm
presenting the real picture of what
america is all about
i have to ask because we've the news
business has changed so much over the
years since i've been in it especially
since you've been in it
how is it that you've been able to
retain this feature
type
happy telling of stories you know the
the feel-good moments when the push is
for heart news hard and fast 20 seconds
a minute 20. how have you been able to
retain that
well it's funny because you know as the
news has gotten harsher let's put it
that way i have worried off and on that
maybe my days are coming to an end as a
reporter because i thought there'd be
more like
there isn't room for this kind of
feel-good thing that i do it turned out
to be just the opposite it turned out
that there was more of an appetite for
it than ever and so now i'm not worried
about losing my job at this point
because i do i do feel like there will
always be an appetite for it and the
worse the world gets the more appetite
there is for it
so it is important
i think it is important you know the way
we structure our news guests you know it
is a construct we put the worst story
that whatever the worst thing that
happened that goes first for no logical
reason nobody ever said that and then
the least important which is usually the
life-affirming thing comes at the end
you know i've talked to my bosses before
i don't switch it around and put and
they laugh at me but maybe someday
you just keep pushing keep pushing if
anyone can do it steve hartman can do it
i know it that's how it's going to work
i have to ask you and this and this is a
this is a tough question because you've
worked for so many years and done so
many incredible stories do you have one
that stands out is there one that is the
most memorable for you
yeah i am asked that sometimes and when
pressed i will say the story of nora and
dan
and that was a story about a little girl
who was in a grocery store and she saw
this grumpy old man and she asked him
for a hug
and what she didn't know what she would
have no way of knowing is that the man
had just lost his wife about six months
earlier and he'd given up his reason for
living
they hugged they became friends and they
were they saw each other every week and
gave him a renewed reason to live and i
like that story because it kind of
symbolizes all the stories
that we look for in that it was about as
insignificant little thing or seemingly
insignificant little thing that made a
huge impact and i think that's a theme
that you'll see through the the on the
road stories you know week in week week
out is something that seems so little
but it somehow just really makes a big
difference in sometimes one person's
life and sometimes many people's lives
and so that's it when forced to choose i
usually choose that one
beautiful story and and tough because
you've done so many you have something
that you're that you're talking about
for memorial day speaking of trying to
get everybody involved you've been doing
it a couple years talk about
your endeavor for taps okay well this
started
many years ago i did a story we'd gotten
an email saying i keep hearing taps i
live in tacoma washington i don't know
where it's coming from so my producer at
the time said well he started digging
down let's try to figure this out we
found a guy named don britton who was
standing on his porch
every day at sunset and he was playing
taps and we went to do a story on this
like what his motivation was
and
what surprised us most on that shoot was
that when he would play
other people would come out and stand on
their balconies stand on their porches
and they would stand their hand over
heart and it was a beautiful thing and i
thought what if all of america could
feel what i was feeling in that moment
and years went by and then the pandemic
happened and
there were no memorial day parades or
ceremonies so we said maybe this is the
year so we started taps across america
and basically what it is is people who
play trumpet or bugle we ask them to
stand on their porches or in their front
yards and play taps and if you don't you
know go out there and just take take a
moment
and we do it at three o'clock on
memorial day which is the moment of
remembrance and take a moment just to
reflect on what the holiday is all about
and we got a huge response and this is
gonna be the third year and we're we're
hoping this becomes like a national
tradition where you know long after i'm
gone this this this carries on music
does soothe the soul as i'm sure you
have discovered in so many of your
stories
is there anything that you want viewers
or other journalists to know about
yourself and about your path
um
that's funny because you know it's been
unusual having my kids you know in the
limelight with me and people being able
to see my family um because normally i
don't like to focus too much on on it
and i still don't want to because you
know as a journalist
we're the storyteller right and
sometimes we do need to be involved in
the story but at the same time the
it's about the people that we're
profiling and i wouldn't really
want any attention focused you know on
myself versus these incredible americans
that i get to meet and share their story
that's really what it's all about
always the humble storyteller thank you
thank you on the road right here in las
vegas we appreciate it thank you
excellent good stuff
okay in our audience anything else you
guys would like to need to ask oh that
was very good so uh so now what we'll do
is we'll roll the tape
that
[Laughter]
i know i'm sure their questions will be
different you know as
we have as you know newsrooms have
changed so much